[Musique]
et nous sommes maintenant en
conversation avec un auditeur en france
par une grande forêt il se trouve à la
campagne il s'agit de monsieur au derby
car il a 75 ans monsieur picard bonsoir
vous avez une question qui porte sur la
loi et le canada et c'est sur quelque
chose qui nous lie une affaire de loin
de quoi s'agit-il
eh bien je me demande qui pouvait rester
au canada des vieilles lois françaises
en particulier le code napoléon qui je
sais une cour un moment au canada qui a
été supprimé au moment de la perte de la
domination française
mais comme nation anglaise est il que
reste-t-il du code napoléon
vous avez parlé de la conquête anglaise
et que ça cesse a mis fin à la pratique
du droit français
ici au canada donc autour de 1759 et
vous avez raison là dessus
sauf qu'on parle pas de l'abolition du
code napoléon à ce moment là puisque le
can napoléon formellement c'est 1804
voici ce qui s'est passé en 1759 que
lorsque les anglais ont décidé on à
coups de bottes militaires que le québec
leur appartenait québec avait un régime
une régime de loi qui était le régime
français
les mêmes lois s'appliquent est ici la
même façon c'est la même façon lorsque
les coutumes de paris coutume de paris
c'est l'expression consacrée
après la conquête britannique il ya une
proclamation de la reine du roi
pardonnez moi qui a volé le droit
français qui a imposé le droit anglais
au québec sauf que ça n'a pas très bien
fonctionné parce que quand quelqu'un
veut résister il peut résister de façon
pas assez il peut vous mettre des bâtons
dans les roues
et c'est ce qu'ont fait les québécois en
disant ah ouais tu veux me juger avec
ton code anglais toi les anglais ont
fini par saisir on va changer en mode et
peut-être que finalement les québécois
ils vont on voit leur donner le droit à
être jugé ou à juger de leur propre
affaire selon un code française selon la
tradition qu'ils ont depuis presque deux
cents ans alors aujourd'hui encore c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
vous avez le canada anglais qui
fonctionne selon la loi molle en anglais
britannique et vous avez le québec qui
en partie le droit civil est fondée sur
le code napoléon iii dans la commune à
quelque chose qui est romain qui a
inspiré la loi allemande pour expliquer
très simplement la commune lors de la
grande bretagne s'est fondé sur des
décisions de juges des tribunaux royaume
alors ça veut dire que lorsque vous avez
une cause devant vous les juges m'ont
rendu une décision qui doit être basée
sur les précédents
il ya une cause similaire dans le passé
qu'est ce que l'autre juge a décidé
c'est sans la commune là c'est la ligne
directrice le juge qu'il faut qu'ils
prennent en considération les précédents
ça c'est la commune et la tradition donc
cette tradition-là de revenir sur les
antécédents ça remonte aux lois romaines
et au début d'un empire romain les lois
et éparpillé il y avait des livres des
recueils de loi des proclamations ya un
an par un des premiers empereurs romains
qui s'appelait justinien qui à dire ces
experts ont à faire le ménage là-dedans
on va réunir ça dans un seul endroit un
seul recueil pour éviter la confusion
est dorénavant les juges vont se référer
aux cas précédents pour déterminer qui a
raison qui a tort dans certaines causes
alors contrairement maintenant aux
tribunaux du quand même là anglophone
were anglo oui c'est ça au québec les
tribunaux de droit civil se réfère
d'abord aux codes ce que dit la loi
qu'est ce que dit la loi bien su est
ensuite en deuxième on va prendre en
considération les décisions antérieures
les jugements antérieurs pour que le
jugement qu'on va proposer dans une
cause se conforment quand même un petit
peu au précédent mais c'est pas la
première donnée que va examiner un juge
lorsqu'il va rendre une décision
vous me demandiez ce qu'il y ait encore
une influence du code fois napoléon au
canada la réponse est oui au québec
maintenant au canada où on peut aussi
dire qu'il ya une influence du code
autochtone sur le cas de lies code
canadien les codes blanca n'a dit il ya
la notion de droits ancestraux s'est
inscrit maintenant dans nos
constitutions dans la loi qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
c'est très très important des faits pour
disons entre guillemets les autochtones
non ben contente et je ne sais pas s'il
me choisit peut-être pas très heureux
c'est pour respecter l'autochtone voilà
un je pense que c'est ça le contente et
je pense qu'ils jamais contents bien
bien des décisions précédentes sur sur
l'occupation de son territoire avec le
général notre ami autochtone est encore
beaucoup de causes présentement devant
nos cours énormément de causes qui sont
en attente d'une décision est très
souvent ses causes
on attend de les entendre pour voir
qu'est ce que va dire l'autre tribunal
donc on se on se réfère ici on anticipe
d'à travers un système juridique basé
sur la commune là sur ce qui va être
décidé bientôt pour voir si ça pourra
influencer la cause que l'on veut
soumettre qui est soumise d'accord donc
est-ce que ça réponde être question de
savoir il reste encore pas mal de choses
de notre merci beaucoup nous avons posé
cette question
monsieur becca gens qui m'a répondu
c'est toujours avec joie
on se retrouve au derby qu'un qui se
trouvent en france
[Musique]